THE DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT.
AND THAT IS "THE ANGLE."
IN JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
COMMERCE HIM AND JIM JORDAN,
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, LET'S START ON THE
BORDER ISSUE, THEN WE WILL GET
BACK TO WHAT ELSE IS COOKING.
WERE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
LATER, BUT THIS IS A NATIONAL
TRAVESTY.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL SAY, OH, IT'S
NOT BAD AT ALL ON THE BORDER,
INTERCEPTION OF PEOPLE ARE DOWN,
FEWER PEOPLE CROSSING PAIRED
WHAT IS THE REAL TRUTH?
>> JUST HEARD ABOUT THE AGENTS
ON THE BOARD, TALKING ABOUT THE
70,000 THIS MONTH ALONE CROSSING
THE BORDER.
WHAT ARE WE ON, THE FIFTH
CARAVAN?
TO WE NEED A SIXTH CARAVAN,
SEVENTH CARAVAN, ENDLESS
CARAVAN, BEFORE WE STAYED AS AN
EMERGENCY?
THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT, AND SOME
OF THE REPUBLICANS WERE OPPOSING
THE PRESIDENT, AS YOU SAID IN
YOUR OPENING, IN YOUR "INGRAM
ANGLE," THE SAME ONES LAST YEAR
DURING CONGRESS, I DIDN'T WANT
TO GET IT DONE WHEN WE HAD
MAJORITY VOTE IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE, LOOKS LIKE THE SENATE IS
GOING TO VOTE TO OVERRULE THE
PRESIDENT'S ORDER, BUT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT VETOES IT AND IT COMES
BACK FOR A VETO, WE CAN SUSTAIN
THE VETO.
>> Laura: MITCH McCONNELL
COULD HAVE PUSHED THIS, COULD
HAVE DEMANDED HIS MEMBERS.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE DONE IT LAST
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: THEY PROMISED THE
PRESIDENT WE ARE GOING TO GET
THE WALL FUNDING, ISN'T THAT
ALWAYS BUT CANNOT YOU DANGLE IN
FRONT OF SOMEONE?
>> WE WILL GET IT LATER, ALWAYS
A MILLION REASONS YOU SHOULDN'T
DO WHAT THE VOTERS ELECTED YOU
TO DO.
>> Laura: YOUR ADVICE TO HIM
IN THIS MOMENT, WE'RE GOING
GOING TO GET INTO THE
IMPEACHMENT SQUAD, PEOPLE, OH,
WE GOT HIM, THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING AROUND HIM, HE GOT THE
ISSUED, IVANKA, JARED, WEIRD
RUSSIANS I'VE NEVER NAMED,
THEY'RE ALL NAMED.
WHAT SHOULD THE PRESIDENT DO?
>> JUST KEEP DOING HIS JOB.
I HAD THE LINCOLN DAY DINNER,
AND THE CROWD WAS HUGE, THEY
WERE SO ENTHUSIASTICALLY
PRESIDENT FIGHTING FOR WHAT HE
TOLD THEM I CAN PEOPLE HE WOULD
DO.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THE 81
LETTERS MR. NADLER SENT, WHAT IS
INTERESTING IS WHO HE DIDN'T
SEND THEM TO.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE, 81
DIFFERENT ENTITIES COME OVER 60
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, BUT HE DIDN'T
SEND IT TO THE TWO MOST
IMPORTANT: GLENN GIBSON AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
GLENN SIMPSON WAS PAID BY THE
CLEMSON TO PUT THE DOSSIER
TOGETHER, HE HIRED CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, A FOREIGNER, TO
WRITE THE DOSSIER.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE, BUT NOT THE
TWO THAT COUNT THE MOST.
LOOK, THEY STARTED THE
IMPEACHMENT EFFORT LAST WEEK
WITH MICHAEL COHEN, AND MICHAEL
COHEN, THEIR FIRST ANNOUNCED
WITNESS OF THE HUNDRED 16TH
CONGRESS, GOING TO PRISON IN TWO
MONTHS --
>> Laura: THAT IS THEIR ACE IN
THE HOLE.
>> LIVE SIX TIMES UNDER OATH.
>> Laura: BILL BARR HAS GOT TO
ACT ON THIS.
I'M SORRY, BILL BARR COULD ACT
ON THIS, COULD BILL BARR REOPEN
INVESTIGATION INTO MRS. CLINTON?
SHOULD HE?
>> WHAT HE SHOULD DO IS TELL US
WHAT JOHN HUBER IS DOING, WHAT
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS DOING, WHAT
THE FISA ABUSE THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE LOOKING INTO, THE WHOLE
IDEA YOU HAVE THE TOP PEOPLE OF
THE FBI, COMEY, McCABE, BAKER,
STRZOK, PAGE COME ALL THESE
PEOPLE IN THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION AND LAUNCHED AND
RAN THE TRUMP-RUSH
INVESTIGATION, THEY'VE ALL BEEN
FIRED, THAT IS WHERE WE NEED TO
LOOK.
>> Laura: THERE IS PLENTY OF
COLLUSION HERE, BUT WHAT ABOUT
TONY PODESTA?
WHY DOES HE SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET AWAY WITH SO MUCH ACTIVITY
WITH RUSSIA.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE,
YOU BEEN GREAT ON THIS, DOUBLE
STANDARD.
ONE SET OF RULES FOR US REGULAR
FOLK --
>> Laura: I WE HAVE A NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN PACE.
NO ONE IS LOOKING TO PUT SCOUTS
ON THE WALL, BUT THIS IS WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE DEALING WITH.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, AT LEAST
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A CLEAR SENSE
OF WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE THIS,
CORRECT?
>> GO BACK AND LOOK AT THIS
FUNDAMENTAL FACT, THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN PAID THE LAW FIRM WHO
HIRED GLENN SIMPSON WHO HIRED A
FOREIGNER, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
TALK TO A COUPLE OF RUSSIANS,
NEVER WENT TO RUSSIA, PUT
TOGETHER THIS FAKE DOCUMENT
CALLED THE DOSSIER THAT THE FBI
USED.
THAT ALL THESE PEOPLE USED,
STRZOK AND PAGE USED, TO GO TO A
SECRET COURT TO GET A WARRANT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS WHAT LAUNCHED IT ALL.
NONE OF THEM ARE GOING TO THE
GUY THAT COUNT THE MOST: GLENN
SIMPSON AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
>> Laura: THAT SIGNED THE FISA
WARRANTS, NOT REVEALING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THEM,
THAT STICKS IN MY CRAW.
>> WE HAVE COMEY SAYING ONE
THING, STRZOK SAYING ONE
THING -- THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
>> Laura: NOBODY PAYS, THOUGH!
THIS IS WHAT DRIVES PEOPLE
CRAZY.
WE HAVE A NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO IS A CONSUMMATE
PROFESSIONAL.
>> WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO HIM
ABOUT THIS.
>> Laura: YOU ARE IN PROCESS
OF TALKING ABOUT THIS?